اسود الاطلس يواصلون كتابه التاريخ
احتفالات عامه للجماهير المغربيه رونالدو
يضرب الدموع بعد الوداع هذا الاخبار
وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
بعد وصولهم لربع نهائي كاس العالم مواصل
اسود الاطلس كتابه التاريخ لفوز على
البرتغال وحجز مكانهم بين الاربعه الكبار
في المونديال وبهذا يكون المغرب اول فريق
افريقي يصل المربع الذهبي من البطوله
وسينتظر الفائز من مباراه فرنسا
عقب هذا الفوز خرجت الجماهير المغربيه في
مختلف مدن العالم احتفالا بهذا الانجاز
التاريخي وشهاده العاصمه الدوحه التي
احتضنت المباراه احتفالات عامه وهو المشهد
ذاته في مدريد برشلونه باريس ومختلف
العواصم والمدن الاوروبيه والعربيه
وعلى مواقع التواصل تصدر المغرب محركات
البحث من قبل المتابعين وبلغت التغريدات
التي تحدثت عن المباراه نحو نصف مليون
تغريده على موقع تويتر وتفاعل رواتب
السوشيال ميديا مع هذا التاهل عبر
التعليقات والتغريدات في مختلف الصفحه
الرياضيه التي تحدثت عن هذا الفوز
رونالدو الذي دخل كبديل في المباراه دخل
في نوبه بوكا مباشره بعد ستره الحكم
ورفقات عدسه الكاميرات كريستيانو في النفق
المؤدي الى غرف الملابس في اخر ظهور له في
منافسات كاس العالم بعد ما اعلن اعتزاله
اللعب الدوليا بعد هذه البطوله